hello and a very warm welcome indeed to
this latest edition of quad Riga coming
to you from the heart of the German
capital Berlin this week we're focusing
on developments in France we're in the
very near future in just a couple of
days time in fact the Euro 2016 soccer
tournament kicks off but ahead of the
tournament there's little sense of
euphoria in fact many parts of the
country have been in the grip of chaos
this after the CGT trade union declared
war on the labor market reforms that
president Francois Hollande and his
government say they are determined to
press through meanwhile with more
strikes ahead the people of France are
still living in fear of another possible
terror attack so our question here today
on quadriga is this crisis in France how
wounded is the grand nastyona to discuss
that question I'm joined here in the
studio by three seasoned observers and
analysts let me introduce them to you
beginning with Pascal tee-ball who is
with Radio France Internacional he says
the trenches of aver done have only now
been filled in but in the rest of France
the rifts are still huge each and every
reform becomes a battle to end all
battles also with us is multi learning
of Berlin's Targa Spiegel newspaper the
believes that Frances economy is showing
signs of improvement Francois Hollande
must stay on course with his reforms and
not give in to left-wing demands and the
warm welcome to tu Geraldine Schwartz a
French TV journalist and documentary
filmmaker who is based here in Berlin
Geraldine says the unions are still
powerful but fewer and fewer French
people supports their confrontational
course they've understood that France
has to change so general Dean I'd like
to begin with you and it's been a
terrible 18 months the last
year-and-a-half for Franz Charlie Hebdo
butter claw state of emergency economic
woes and so on and so forth
give me an idea of what impact that has
had in France in emotional terms well I
think France is really having very
difficult times in the last year but
most important I think is to focus on
what these true
could change in the country and I think
the trauma of the terrorist attacks
brought the French people together so
there was a real solidarity movement
which I considered to be quite positive
the problem now is that with the strikes
this solidarity has been shaken and I
see frost divided in two with one side
still having a very romantic view of
protest and trade unions and the other
half realising that force has to change
consider the challenges in a globalized
world that France is facing now and of
course part of these French people who
are willing of change the unemployed
people who are more than 10% of the
country and they are actually willing to
change so the the paradox is that the
people who are in the street and with
the trade unions are those most of them
who are actually having a job hmm so be
a little bit more about the romantic
view that you just talked about there of
strikes and protests yes there is
specific to France it appears well I
think the the trade unions are very
linked with the history of liberation
and resistance during the Second World
War
so this is where starts the romantic
view of the trade unions but if one
looks gives a more precise look the
evolution in the 30 years is that the
train unions are less and less powerful
because they are less and less members
either even in bastions like the fields
like energy where the CGT which is
leading the protest were right now had
40 percent of the workers in
in in this field were unionists and in
the 30 last year it was cut in two so
this gives this gives an orientation and
also even if the polls says that almost
half of the French are against the this
law it doesn't mean they are actually
supporting the trade unions and a very
recent poll said that seven from out of
ten French people are actually
distrusting the head of the city yes
these are very interesting first let's
just talk about the backdrop to the code
that divided France the current backdrop
is there is the build up to the Euro
2016 football tournament pascal france
is hosting the tournament obviously 51
matches i've been i've been reading that
it's a the tournament is set to bring
1.3 1.2 or 1.3 billion euros into the
country it was supposed to be a great
sporting spectacle a time of joy that's
not how it feels at this point in time i
sense yeah that's true
it means we still have yeah more or less
one week to go till the beginning of the
competition so there is still hope but
of course it's it's supposed to be a
period of joy it's very important also
for the government for the mage of
France of course abroad but also for
yeah to to improve maybe the mood of the
French or the French population which is
a which is nowadays not actually the
best and there are also maybe some
economical problems linked to these
strikes if if the strikes will go on
after the beginning of the of the
competition as multi leaming has already
said there are some signs showing this
that the the French economy is improving
and that is also one of the one of the
one of the arguments of the government
saying that it would be a narrow - yeah
-
to interrupt is good evolution it is the
new mantra of control on to say more or
less every day
France is going better sevim you the
French people are not absolutely
convinced but there are some statistics
some showing that there are some
improvements but the situation situation
generally speaking is remains quite bad
and the mood of the people is especially
very very bad not everybody in France is
convinced mother perhaps its if we if we
pronounce it on slowly improving not
improving but slowly improving we have
the I think growth of 0.5% some better
mood in investments and things like that
it's very very slowly the hard times are
for the unemployment rate especially
young unemployment 25% or 24% and more
than 10% the unemployment rate at all
that means that the that the expenditure
for for social services unemployment
support and everything like this is very
high and it stays high and it almost the
the depth rate is almost a hundred
percent I think it's the 15th out of
18th years when it's above the
Maastricht criteria of national debt
that is allowed and and these are these
are bad signs for for itself if you see
signs for improving that might even
spare the opposition saying if we
improve why we need all the reforms so
this could be a backdrop in the argument
of President Hollande what we see is a
battle of two very very weak parties
president alone this week because of I
think it's 14 or 15 percent of support
of his policy and the CGT is is
struggling for survival for foreign in
between the Union trade trade unions and
because the second largest trade union
already supported the reformist agenda
of president alone so we have two very
very convinced sides but very weak side
this explains the fierceness of the
fight mmm we're talking about the fight
you nodding geraldine no well actually
I think I think we should all always
consider the situation today in
comparison to the situation for example
in 95 when there was one of the hugest
strike ever in France and there were
more than 2 million people in the
streets so I don't think that the the
conference I think the confrontation
today is useful in order maybe to have
the trade unions reform the trade unions
have to reform it's not only about
you're acting as though all of this this
confrontation on the streets of France
Pascal was comparing it in the quote
that I had at the beginning of the show
- they're done he was talking about the
Battle of all battles France is a
battlefield and you're telling me that
it's a kind of theater political theater
and nothing more no there are a hundred
fifty between 150 and 300 thousand
people when the street last Thursday in
all from so I'm just comparing the
figures you know and this is also
something that we have to say there are
no mass demonstrations in the street but
there is one big difference compared
with the huge strikes 19 to 95 against
the the the the Bill of the former prime
ministership a and order strikes in the
last years also during the reign of
Nicholas Sarkozy it is the first strike
with this dimension against left-wing
government the last one was in the 80s
so it is it is a different of course it
is a big challenge maybe a historical
one and I know for a left-wing
government in in France and it is also I
think it's more or less a culture fight
between the CGT former communist Union
more or less and the reformist wants the
second Union the CF DT and also
president who now more or less wants to
make France more or less like a little
German more social democrat
okay we'll talk about in just a second
we did we haven't yet quite identified
whether we're talking about a sort of an
abstract field of conflict or a or a
fierce battlefield but certainly what we
know what that what the conflict is all
about at this point in time it's
focusing very much on working conditions
let's just get some numbers and some
facts here it's one of the world's most
far-reaching welfare states French
workers are allowed to retire in their
early 60s they only have to work 35
hours a week and the minimum wage is
almost 10 euros an hour but the French
still love to go on strike more than any
other nation in Europe do they have
reason to unemployment has dropped
slightly but it's still a whopping 24
percent among the countries use small
and mid-sized businesses have a tough
profits just can't keep up with wages
Social Security payments and a heavy tax
burden the French president hopes the
changes will create new jobs by giving
employers more flexibility to fire and
negotiate working hours and bonuses
directly with workers currently they
have to adhere to sectoral agreements
but is reform even possible in France
that's the question is reform even
possible in France Sheldon yes well I
think that it is possible for half of
the people and it's not possible for the
other half for us it's really divided
which is a new figure because I think a
couple of years ago we are the figure
would maybe more be at 17:30 it was the
- laughs good to fill me in on who these
two halves are that you're talking about
I think in one of the half it's the
young people who are frightened of
unemployment they also see I mean they
travel a lot they they are more open
some of them had experiences in Britain
and Germany so they are also used maybe
to other conditions they are more open
to it and and one I mean part of the
other half I would say is quite
old-fashioned people whose fear of the
future I also understand because the
future is unknown for everybody in
Europe so I think it's more the fear of
change which is also what was talking
about but I don't think we can say that
Frances is is incapable of reforms I
think this is this is the test this is a
very important test right now
and if Iran fails I don't care if he's
not elected next year but what is
important is that this will be again and
discouragement
to make further reforms so it's in this
on this point it is a very very
important conflict right let's go you're
looking very thoughtful yeah I think I
think it's possible to of course to have
reference forum but the difficulty is
that we don't have a society like in
Germany where there is a lot of dialogue
where we have a lot of strong
organization between the people and the
government and
you usually have a new bill like the new
one sometimes there is dialogue in the
before with the different organization
with the employers with the the trade
unions but there is a new bill which is
which is adopted and afterwards there
are big strikes so and that that is what
the government tried to do in the at the
beginning after the election of francois
hollande to organize dialogue between
trade unions and employers organization
to find a solution and the solution or
the solution which which were adopted
became afterwards bill so it would be it
would be a better solution I think and
of course the difficulty nowadays is the
is the strong unpopularity of the
governement and the factors alone now
starts new reforms which probably would
have been it would have been better to
introduce them at the beginning after it
is election but he but he had a program
and he was elected on a quiet left-wing
program of these reforms four years ago
would have would have been impossible we
saw 1995 what happened with Jacques
whence a month after he introduced
reforms which were completely different
from his program but I will add
something to to the dialogue thing which
I totally agree with you adding
something means to add the honesty it's
not just dialogue we need honesty we I
mean I have the German glasses on so so
I remember quite well the chance to get
hurt Rhoda when he introduced the agenda
2010 and he from the beginning said it
will be painful we need to support
people what we have to demand something
from the people so I don't see that the
president alone right now is is being
seen as honest as ki ashraddha was when
he introduced the reformist agenda so
he's always saying we all will be better
off but there will be pain
full and what what what it means it if
we look not abstract but in concrete
terms what kind of painfulness we will
receive this is lacking totally in
France Schroeder had the chance to have
totally other mentality in the trade
unions in Germany and therefore I
totally understand what he's saying I
mean the the trade unions in France
first it's seven percent it would they
represent seven percent of the workforce
18 percent in Germany and second they
are not at the supervisory board of the
companies this is a very big difference
so they are not actually they don't face
the problems of the companies so they
don't understand their challenges I know
they have a power which they don't
really deserve I mean it's it's in the
it's it's in the written into the laws
in France that you have political
strikes but that's what is done right
now it's not that you if you go in the
to participate at the supervisor report
to understand the problem of the company
and also the trade unions and France are
much more defending the wages and in
Germany they have a ratifying the the
work the employment this is so there are
a they are able to make sacrifice in
order to save employment so they have a
much more they look much more further in
advance than the French trade unions we
have only spoken about the trade unions
but I mean the capacity to have a
dialogue is also necessity for the
employers organization and when the
chairmen of the employers organization
in France the mid-depth may compares the
CGT the trade unions with terrorists I'm
not sure it will improve the dialogue
yeah okay
let's move on a little bit with some
pictures because yeah I mean you're
talking about the the role of the trade
unions in all this and the clash with
Francois Hollande it's very much turning
out to be a clash between the hardline
trade union leader Phyllida Martine a
the head of the CGT the CGT the powerful
trade union and France while on let's
have a little look at that before we
continue the discussion
the protests in France are being
organized by one confrontational figure
in particular Philippe Martinez the head
of its oldest union the CGT
has declared the government an enemy of
the people and insists it has to give in
the workers have their say and the
government needs to listen the ball is
in the government's court if they tell
us we're going to start all over again
it'll all stop straight away I guarantee
it
the battle for workers rights and France
has turned into a public war of words
between two figures Francois Hollande is
fighting for his political survival and
re-election and 2017 I want to make this
law that I consider to be a law of
progress a law for all the law of walls
but can the French president pushed
through his reforms or will the protests
drive him to his knees
Pascal tebow who's gonna win this but
this battle between mr. Martinez and mr.
Hollande I think the the best solution
would be if there are no losers because
it's important of course for the
government not to withdraw is its text
otherwise it along we would lose the the
rest of credibility he has and this
credibility is very little and it's
important I think that the CGT also we
have already spoken about that because
it's also a struggle for the CGT for the
future of this trade union and it is
important also that day that they don't
that they don't lose formally so maybe
the the solution would be not to
withdraw the the article 2 of the bill
which is the central content but maybe
the government could accept some
compromises about some other aspects of
the bill so every the government and the
trade union and the CGT could at the end
yeah
show up like like winners or like half
losers I don't know we're talking about
winners and losers surely there were the
more maybe I'd like to ask this question
who are the winners in all this and that
the foulness you know could be I mean
the overall mood is if people are not
willing for they in principle support
reforms 70 percent saying yes we see the
necessity that we need reforms 70
percent are against the specific reforms
program so we always have this kind of
contradictory overloaded by by a general
sense of injustice that we see in all of
Europe since the financial crisis in
2008 when when the government were
supporting all these banks falling bangs
and then things like this with the text
monies and so on the so general sense of
of the elite is doing what they want
they collect all the money they want but
we have to pay for this on the agenda of
a reformist policy so this is overloaded
overloaded by this general and move so
this makes it very very difficult but I
think sometimes I mean you're always
it's always a non brainer to say that in
politics you have to make compromises
nobody has to lose sometimes people have
to lose
maybe the CGT has to lose this battle
because the the heart of the reformist
agenda from which president alone says
if the cornerstone or the heart of my
policy as a president has to survive
there could be I mean compromises for
like five or ten percent but not for the
heart of this reformist agenda otherwise
it will not be a compromise but a lost
battle for president alone you would
talk about 50 percent of French society
that you understand but our sort of
unwilling to change and marine lepen
with the throng as soon as she is
offering these people a vision of a sort
of a National worker's paradise is that
a convincing vision in any shape or form
attack that could that be the future for
France could she be the next president
and that there and that the her economic
vision I don't think she has an economic
vision at all that's one of her big
biggest weakness is economy actually and
most of the time in interviews in
economy questions she just just doesn't
have any answer she doesn't have an
economic problem I mean she wants the
France to go back to the phone you know
she wants wants to go out of the
European Union this is not an economic
program but I think she she can she can
just she of course the winner if there
are two losers the winner is her you
know mmm but she's fueling I would say
these she's fueling the ideology of
there's this corrupt immoral elite
structure that we have to fight been
going on for a long time this idea of
the elite being corrupt and being far
away from the people coming from this
kodokor from Paris this is this is not
really new I think I'm not even sure she
can really win anything out of this
strike I don't know I haven't seen any
just before college is a stunning figure
I read while I was were reading up for
the program BIA researchers at Edinburgh
universe
believe that they can show that 53% of
French voters would like to hold their
own vote like the Briggs it in the UK
that everybody's talking about here they
would like to hold their own vote on the
possible threads it does that does that
sound plausible to you
yeah the freqs it is also is also
something France is talking about I
think it's absolutely anujan and we the
flex it of course the European Union
will come to an end without France I
think it doesn't doesn't make any sense
but yeah there that's also as jihad inna
already already has said that's one of
the proposal also of Mahina pen and of
course is economical purple or
economical proposals are absolutely
nonsense but I think but she she she is
probably nowadays the National is the
party we which attract most of the
workers in France and in the diverse
thing also to see how the the contacts
are the relations on a new it's of
course in formula or in the basis each
win Workers Party or between workers
from the CGT and members of the national
because they want to do something for
the workers to convince them there is
another solution which is wrong okay
well thank you very much for that
Geraldine thank you to motor thanks very
much for joining me I hope we given you
plenty of food with all the question we
were trying to answer is how wounded is
the grand Nessie a grand Nessie on I
hope you've enjoyed the show come back
next week if you have bye-bye just